I've known you a long time and I knew
that that Krispy Kremes has always been
that's your Achilles heel Chris don't
know anymore mean I do it anymore but
I'm saying oh well I also do a thing
where when I drove by Krispy Kreme it
was like my own game and if the light
was on that said they were warm and
fresh I'm going in no light don't go in
right however I learned if you drive
around the block a couple times sensors
in the road or something it goes on
right I'm going in right I go in and I
order the same amount every time not one
but also not 6 because 6 has a name half
dozen yeah well that doesn't sound good
yeah two is a couple fine but two is
also part of a group known as some two
to five is some donuts so if someone
said to Jimmy don't you had some donuts
they picture two maybe three and then I
get a nonfat milk just cuz I like it not
trying to save calories I'm eating some
donuts okay sure now she'll be in there
in the Duncan and the Dunn's not Dunkin
Donuts Krispy Kremes Dunkin Donuts is
better coffee than Donuts but
nonetheless delightful yeah all right so
I've said I sit down I relax I take my
time I look over I see a guy and I
always get just plain glazed that's
plenty of yeah you know yeah okay so I
look over and there's a guy and he's got
chocolate-covered doughnuts he's got
like some I think maybe half dozen now
mind you at Krispy Kreme they just
poured chocolate over the glaze and I
think what a pig I mean
do you need you judging this guy wait
wait there's more and look at the guy
again see it vividly
so he's eating the chocolate doughnuts
Judy's drinking chocolate milk
what kind of pig has chocolate milk
donut or is this yeah so what is lost
control
yeah problem I've always heard and again
you know I'm not a recreational drug
user and I'm not just saying that just
not what is your medical condition stuff
lots of different things yeah okay right
yeah you need to pet your puppy yeah I'm
going from home from here yeah I'll be
with my puppy yeah puppy can't wait
little Mazzy
terrier mixing them in love you but now
that you're smoking marijuana on a
regular basis doesn't that give you the
munchies make you crave the the Krispy
Kreme more than ever
no that was a byproduct no I mostly
nothing crazy cigarette I'm sleeping and
you know what I'm doing what dreaming
about Donuts right I have some donut to
my sleep I don't do it oh I've ruined
every oh it's fake
yeah right that's nice that's nice
you